The talk is going to be related the monadic
functional reactive programming stuff, I won't
mention any of those words by name, if you
weren't paying attention, that's fine.
Also, I'm badelling a cold right now, but
luckily I have your country's medicine for
all things, I'll be using this maybe throughout
the talk, but just want to apologize if I
have a horse voice.
So the title is functional layout.
Updating Dom.
I want to pledges what these words mean to
me, for layout all I mean is rectangles on
a browsers in a screen.
Their positions, their orientations, heights
and widths.
Updating the DOM at 60 frames per second‑‑
whether they're scrolling, animating or doing
responsive design, all these things are happening
continuously, that's something I want to talk
about.
And functional has two meanings, it's‑‑
yeah, double meaning and I'll be talking about
both of those here.
The fist one is what does it mean for layout
to be disfunctional.
And I would say that layout isn't disfunctional
at all for static or mostly static web sites,
when you a few animations maybe they're simple
an animation in or out or their web site isn't
that isic at all the layout primitives that
we have are perfect.
But, if we're to compare ourselves to native
layouts, I'd say it's a real libraries constrained
language, especially for continuous motion.
When it comes to coordinating animations,
I don't think the web is really well suited
for that, I don't they we have a strong language
to express it.
So, what's holding layout back?
There's the obvious one that a lot of people
talk about which is performance, and usually
that comes down to reflow being really costly,
especially when you have a nested DOM, many
Elements are dependent on the layout of other
Elements, so once one Element changes the
browser has to do expensive calculations,
but I think something that we don't talk about
is expressibility.
And I'd say that we don't actually have the
right primitives, the right language to real
libraries talk about doing rich animations
coordinated Gesture based kind of layout that
we see in the native world.
, the three pillars of the web.
And we can ask where does layout belong.
And layout is the purview of HTML and CSS,
HTML usually you don't think about doing anything
with layout, but HTML makes it's own opinions
on layout, the normal browser flow, block
Elements are placed underneath each other
and to the side of one another, and you can
think that CSS is really just there to modify
the flow in a separation of concerning kind
of way‑‑ tons of layouts in CSS, but
it's important to know that HTML also makes
an opinion on layout, we have this idea of
layout and it's inside of two objects.
The whole point of separation of concern is
that HTML should not be concerned about layout.
And then there's the lonely guy JavaScript,
out to the side and youthy that JavaScript
is being able to modify CSS on the fly or
maybe HTML 2.
But, usually when we think about layout we
tonight think about JavaScript, and that's
what I'd Reich to change.
If I were to organize these HTML would be
static layout, CSS would be about a binary
form of layout.
You might change a color, you an animation,
still you're flippage switch, you're not continuously
changing a piece of data even though the animation
is continuous, you're just turning on and
off and queuing a continuous thing.
Doing like a swipe Gesture, I even just the
most basic thing like that, that I like to
create is you need to include JavaScript..
There's no way to do that?
Just HTML and CSS by itself.
So I talked about the separation concerns,
HTML is supposed to be just about content,
but many people find themselves in this tag
soup where they start wrapping the actual
content and other tags just to do something
about presentation.
Flex Box goes a long way in helping this but
Flex Box also has reflow problems, I don't
think it's‑‑ it's great solution for
some things, but I'd like something a little
bit more powerful.
So, I have a question, why do we use HTML
for presentation?
If we really had this abstraction of concern,
you would never even see this, you would have
some other way of saying that the <div>, the
content is centered.
It wouldn't be an HTML.
And my answer to this question is that it's
the only tree around.
And layout is necessarily a tree kind of data
structure, things are provisioned relative
to other things, so you have this natural
tree that comes out of play.
But there is no other tray in the way, there's
just HTML, you can think that CSS is like
a tree that's cascading, but that's just a
layer on top of the HTML tree.
So, not that that's a bad idea, but what I'm
about to
say might be a bad idea.
I have this idea.
You can
tell me if it is bad.
Can we virtualise, can we
actually separate the virtue of concerns where
we have
our position layer where we turn some layout
DOM things
and flatten it out into style, we do the inside
of
JavaScript, is there some way to go from the
top to the
bottom.
Browsers always do this anyway, because they
draw things to the bottom of the screen.
This is what
they do.
These slides are a few years old.
But I'm
pretty sure that things are similar ... now
Chrome uses
blink, but Chrome and Safari use WebKit as
a rendering
engine and Firefox uses Gecko, and they both
have this
thing called a render tree or frame tree,
in the case of
Gecko, and what this is is just a representation
of your
document in terms of rectangles.
So Gecko takes your
DOM and CSS styles and past everything and
at some point
pipeline, the only thing that they care about
are
rectangles on the screen ... then they paint
those
rectangles with your content, okay?
So what I'd like to
do is take this part out of the browser and
into the
hands of the developer.
The way we do that is kind of
crazy.
We position absolute things in CSS.
This isn't
everything, just things we want to animate.
The things
we think are presentational and not to do
with content.
We create our own render tree in JavaScript.
So that
way, by positioning absolute everything in
CSS we've
taken it out of the browser's normal flow
and have
manual positioning on things.
So we can create this
render tree in JavaScript, it is pretty ghetto
version
of a tree here, bunch of nodes and the leaves
of this
tree are actual HTML dips.
We can give these nodes some
kind of layout properties, maybe some translation,
if we
give A and B these translation values we'd
expect,
before it touches the DOM, that we can flatten
this and
style the DOM 150 pixels by 200 pixels.
Just a
combination of the two previous nodes.
And we can be
clever with other layout properties too, but
things on
CSS, the percentage based properties we can
define CU
with some kind of size and align the relative
to that
size, so that would be just C and D would
be
a combination of 50 pixels to the right, and
25 pixels
down combined with translate for A, and we
get 150 by
225.
Oh God.
Everyone should use GPG.
Oh, I have due
module.
Okay.
So just to remind me when the demos are,
actually.
So the logical conclusion of this, if we take
it to the point of absurdity, is to build
a tree in
JavaScript, or build a tree in HTML, but actually,
everything is flat.
If we inspect the element here --
and I scroll down here -- that's the first
node second
node all of these things are on the exact
same level.
It is entirely flat.
So you can do this in CSS, you'd
have some crazy nesting thing going on, the
layers.
There is content here and I just tried to
be -- can you
see that?
There is content inside of these, this little
smiley face and just for effect I put it inside
two
spans.
You can nest whatever you want inside of here,
but the important thing is that the outside
is flat.
Not the content.
And close this for a second.
And we
can animate this tree also.
So the whole point is to
have all these animations going on, and we
avoid the
problems of reflow here because everything
will one it
is all hardware accelerate you learned what
that meant
in the last talk and two, everything is flat
so the DOM
has to do very little calculation.
So you can imagine
there is this tree going on, and just the
numbers inside
the nodes are changing and trickle down, so
one branch
moves and moves all the other branches, and
then you
have this funny tree.
Okay.
Back to the talk.
You
weren't supposed to see that.
Okay, so you might have seen this like plaster
on
the surface, so this is Samsara, is this library
I've
been writing.
It is originally where Myles and I both
worked, and it is meant to kind of be a language
for
this kind of stuff, and some of the ideas
are similar.
With layout and JavaScript, the question is
what can we
now do?
And I have this theory that CSS was always
designed for point and click.
You have power tribute or
you have animation that goes on and off; it
is not about
continuous motion.
The JavaScript can be.
That's the
whole point.
I'm super excited about streams, as you
can tell.
That's largest font size in the entire talk
and all these ideas, the functional reactive
programming
too, you might have seen in the other talks,
because we
can think about CSS not as this tree but one
giant
stream.
So streams are kind of the language for
continuous motion or just kind of continuous
data flow
at all.
So let me give you -- show you a demo of what
I mean.
That's a little bit abstract from the previous
one.
Yes.
So this demo also works on any of your
mobile phones or computers and stuff, if you
go to that
address, that O is an O and not a zero.
But this demo
is supposed to mimic some of the ideas from
the native
world specifically the IOS navigation controller
where
you give it -- it does the menuing interface
for you.
It allows you to have a back put in and it
does all
these crazy transitions when you go back between
some
kind of pages that you have in your application.
So
there's a lot of things going on here.
When you drag,
here I'll just drag first, and then explain
later.
That's all the demo does.
Pretty much.
But there's a
lot going on.
So you can see things will pass at
different rates.
I was trying to be neurotic to emulate
IOS.
They translate, the drawer you see the red
part
actually comes out, but then it doesn't move
for
a little while.
You can see all these kinds of crazy
effects with streams and stream transforms,
and more
than that, the way that this code is written
is the way
I think about it.
The opacity of my nav bar is
listening to the motion of the draw, which
is listening
to the mouse input I'm giving from my dragging.
In
a lot of other animation libraries they give
you the
ability the wrap-in mode and then animate
some CSS
property, and that's great.
You want to change one
thing, have someone enter or exit animation,
that's
fine, but I want you to feel like you're a
conductor of
an orchestra and everything is interrelated
because this
is the kind of experience that we have in
the native
world.
You don't realise it but when you press the
back
button on IOS or android eight, different
animations are
happening.
And I actually think this is part of what
makes those interfaces so fun to use.
You can also
click on the message button in the backbone.
Yes.
So
this is all done in the language of streams.
Everything
is a stream, the mouse input is a stream,
the layout
itself is a stream because the blue thing
is actually
emitting a bunch of numbers from zero to one,
and it
is -- if you think that my mouse input is
going from
right to left, it gets clamped at some point,
and so
only ones are being admitted from the blue
thing then
the nav is listening to the blue thing, and
that's all
these things are being piped together.
That's how this
demo works.
And I think the whole thing is about 300
lines of code, but there are other frames
that allow you
to give you these two pages, and then let
you give you
that animation, and they make it extremely
simple.
But
to customise it is almost impossible.
So what I'm
trying to do is to make simple things medium
difficulty,
but make hard things just as medium difficulty.
So I'm
trying to come with the primitives in order
to give you
the power to do whatever kind of animations
you want.
Okay, so I've already lied to you.
The render tree
isn't a tree at all in the Samsara framework
I'm making.
It's one big stream.
That's, to me, kind of a nerdy
cool part and I love to talk about the technical
parts,
especially to some of the Pascal people that
were
speaking before, but the whole idea is the
nodes contain
streaming data and then they -- the child
nodes listen
to the parent modes and when they change they
send data
down to the children, all the way down until
it exits in
the DOM in the form of transform or parsity
or size
properties, all the layout things I essentially
need.
And this has a lot of technical benefits,
you don't,
like normally you think of a tree as like
you have node
and then it has a range of children and you
might call
render on the root node, and it calls render
on the
children and recursively goes down, but when
you think
of it as one big pipeline, you can do things
like you
have optimal subtree rendering, you don't
ever have to
past the entire tree, when one thing changes
it will
naturally cascade down.
You don't need to do any dirty
checking, but there are tonnes of things you
avoid with
this streaming interface because there is
no spate the
way that it goes down div from one function
to another
function to another, transforming the data,
composing it
and there's an algebra for all of this.
So transforms
essentially multiply, size on the line might
combine
with some other ways.
So these are all transforms that
trickle all the way down into the DOM.
Dug said that is
write programmes to handle text streams, because
that's
an interface.
You're often using text streams and that
was part of the reason the node was so successful,
you're always using the streaming language,
and it is
because they wrap themselves around their
file system
base which is about using these streams and
what I'd
like to convince people because I don't think
we
normally think about it, is that continuous
motion
inside of layer can be thought of as a stream,
and JSON
indicts the universal interface.
Okay.
Maybe you
shouldn't listen to me.
But none of this is new either, for the web.
Okay,
the web started us off with streams, we've
just
blissfully forgotten about, and every single
DOM event
is just a stream.
Mouse move, there is other ones,
scroll, resize, etc, the DOM starts us off,
but the cool
thing about streams is you can take one and
then move it
into another, you can transform it.
So what's lacking
is the ability to pipe the streams around.
If we have
those built, there are so many things we can
do.
In the
demo I showed before, I had this layout which
was
subscribing to the mouse input and chaining
itself, whatever.
Am, but you can have gesture recognition So
you're taking the touch input and it's historically
accumulating some of the events and then you
figure out oh this was a swipe left or somebody
drew a circle or something but this is the
right language where you build higher level
streams on top of lower level streams, calculay
the velocity from scrolling, maybe you'retracking
two fingers at a time maybe you want to have
a stream that turns that into a pinch to zoom,
whatever that means, there's tons more I can
think of.
And what I'm trying to do is come up with
the right language to talk about this stuffer,
I think with ease of expression, people can
suddenly begin to experiment more, they can
do things they didn't normally try.
We have had track and drop for a while, who
remembers not having‑‑ scroll, crazy,
it feels so weird.
Bounce to refresh, the hamburger menu, the
question is can you just insert your own here,
can you just start playing and come up with
something.
So here I start playing.
This was souper silly, that's also ability
you can play around with it.
But, yeah, everything's in 3 D also so you
can change skews and Translates around D spacement
it's putting the mouse input
I guess Genealogy use this type of accordian
thing when it collapses and expands threads,
so believe it or not, it can be useful.
All right, so, just some closing thoughts.
I think a lot of us would say that in the
past 20 year it is public internet has done
a lot to change society, maybe the most impactful.
Maybe more debatable is in the past ten years
than mobile has done a lot to change society.
But as Myles introduced my, I've been traveling
for a while, I've been to some remote places,
maybe a year ago I would of said, mobile's
pretty important, but, I was in Myammar, already,
pretty kind of closed off, I was in the mountains
there with these people that are completely
autonomous from their central government.
And there's a girl, I had a camera with me,
I gave her the camera, she started taking
all these pictures, I showed her how to move
back and forth.
She'd never seen a camera before.
And but her first instinct when she was looking
at the camera was she swiped the screen.
And I couldn't, I didn't understand, you've
never seen a camera before how do you know
there's a Gesture (Laughs) and through the
guide he translated oh, well, I somebody in
thevillage has smartphone and we play becames
on it, and we charge it with the solar power
that we get from, you know, our solar panels,
and I was just like, mobile is everywhere,
I mean, really, I didn't quite understand.
And this happened several times.
People in Myammar gamble over mobile games,
it's so interesting to see.
Any way.
So, I
definitely have this opinion that mobile has,
in terms of it's pervasiveness transformed
the world.
But the whole is not greater than the sum
of it's parts, the mobile web is certain like
that.
I'm not traying to package up a dream that
the mobile web will win or anything like that,
I've been around that would, that I'd like
to do is industry to say it that's important
to work on.
That's what I found my traveling, here's a
potential future I can think of for the mobile
web.
I think of a mobile web can actually change
the economy of applications, apps can be downloaded,
sorry, maybe I should say downloaded by hyper
link, I can text you an application.
I can tweet an application, these are the
ways of distributing apps.
That are comet pleatly de‑centralled, I
adopt have to go to an App store.
How many apps have you downloaded the way
we think about down loading apps and looking
at web sites.
Everything has a browser, whether it's this
computer in my phone or maybe the TV or your
car Am, there is no problem in an apple phone
communicating with an android phone when it's
over the browser but there might be a problem
if it's air drop So everything has a browser
and it can be the layer that unites all the
other things.
You can I mean searching in the apple store
sucks you can crawl through apps, and that
data can be any
other app that can use that, but also have
a layer on
top of it that crawls it.
And I'm really big on this
idea of ephemeral apps, so what I mean by
that is since
there's very little barrier to downloading
an app, you
never have to really think about it because
you never
think about opening a tab in your browser.
It is not
like that, and I can open this tab, am I going
to
uninstall this tab later?
I mean, imagine just walking
into a department store and they text you
this
application that just has all of the inventory,
and you
can search it, or maybe even just try to access
their
wi-fi, and that's the website, their website,
and that
shows their application, and you get rid of
the apps by
closing the tab, so you never have to worry
about it.
Not only can the mobile web compete with native,
but it
has all these other things going for it, that
we're not
really exploring.
So yeah, with that, that's it.
Thank
you.
That's my Twitter.
That's what the code is.
Yeah.